hello and welcome to this episode of
apogee accelerators in this video we'll
demonstrate how to use apogee to secure
apis using Json web tokens
Json web token also known as JWT or jot
is an open standard that describes a
compact and secure way to transfer
information between two parties
the information is contained in a set of
claims encoded as a Json object which
can be digitally signed and also
encrypted Json web tokens offer some
advantages over opaque access tokens as
they're a self-contained token that
doesn't require the recipient to make
additional requests to validate or
retrieve information
in a typical scenario an application
that needs to send information about
itself or a user may generate a job and
send this to the receiving API as a
bearer token using the authorization
header
the server will verify the incoming
token and decode it to retrieve any
claims contained within it apogee offers
three policies for handling jots the
generate job policy allows customers to
generate a new token and return it to
the client or attach it to the request
sent through to the Target backend
the verified job policy is used to
verify tokens and extract claims finally
the decode job policy allows you to
decode a token without verifying it
apogee also has similar policies for
working with Json Webb signature which
is another standard in the same family
of specifications
this sample contains a proxy that shows
you how to generate and verify tokens
the proxy allows you to generate tokens
using the rs-256 algorithm which
requires a public private key pair
the deployment script for this sample
generates the key pair and stores it in
a key value map during the deployment
the sample also shows how to verify the
token signature using the public key and
decrypt using the private key
if you attempt to modify the token or
send a token which is expired apogee
will return a 401 unauthorized response
if the token's valid the verification
endpoints will output the contents of
the decoded token showing the claims and
the algorithm that was used to generate
it now let's see how to deploy it and
use the sample
in order to run this sample you'll need
the following an apogee X instance
provisioned with access configured for
external traffic
as a user you'll need permissions to
deploy API proxies and create key value
map entries
this can be granted through the apogee
org admin role or the API plus
environment admin roles
to deploy this sample you'll also need
the command line tools shown here if
you're using Google Cloud shell these
are already installed
you can click the cloud shell tutorial
link to begin
now that you're in the cloud shell
environment you can follow the
step-by-step instructions
first change to the directory for this
sample to deploy the sample first open
up the env.sh file and set the
configuration to reference your apogee
project external hostname and the
environment name
next run the included script to deploy
the sample this may take a minute to
complete
when the script completes you should see
a message showing the proxy URL and a
set of sample code commands
first set the proxy URL environment
variable
next run the first code command to
generate assigned jot
you should see the value of the token
returned in the output
now you can use the next code command to
verify and decode the token returned
from the previous request
if it's successful you should see a
response containing jot OK followed by
the decoded contents of the token you
can try modifying the token and
replaying the verify request this time
you should receive an invalid token
error
this is because modifying the contents
invalidates the digital signature
next you can follow the remaining two
commands to generate and verify an
encrypted job
notice this time the decoded output also
contains the encryption header
if you copy the token into an external
tool like jot.io you'll see the contents
are garbled because the token is
encrypted
now let's take a quick look at the proxy
deployed in this sample
go to the apogee management UI at
apogee.google.com
under the API proxies section you should
see the Json web tokens proxy select the
proxy and go to the develop tab
the generate signed endpoint uses the
generate drop policy to generate
assigned token
the policy config references the private
key and algorithm sets the expiry time
and also specifies several other claims
to be included in the token the verify
signed endpoint uses the verified job
policy to verify the incoming token
this time the policy specifies the
public key to use to validate the
signature and also the expected value of
the claims contained within the token
the generate encrypted and verify
encrypted endpoints are configured in a
similar way however this uses the public
key to encrypt the token and uses the
private key to decrypt the token during
verification notice the verification
policies also specify a Time allowance
value of 30 seconds this provides an
extra grace period for the token's
validity window finally the proxy also
contains two endpoints you can use to
Output the values of the public and
private keys
the keys themselves are stored in a key
value map which you can find under the
environments section
now you've seen how to use apogee's
built-in policies to handle Json web
tokens
when you're done with the sample you can
provide us with your feedback and then
you can use the cleanup script to delete
the configuration that was deployed to
your Google Cloud project
we hope you found this useful and if you
enjoyed the video please hit the like
button below you can also subscribe to
our channel to see more videos in the
apogee accelerator series and if you
have questions please post them on the
apogee Community thanks for watching